موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله قال مرسل الجزيره انفجارات
قويه ومتتاليه دوت في جنوب ام درمان
رافقتها انفجارات مماثله وقعت في غرب
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ياتي هذا
التطور الميداني بعد اقل من ساعه من
انتهاء اتفاقنا لوقف اطلاق النار وقعه
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع في
مدينه جده برعايه سعوديه امريكيه لمده 24
ساعه وذلك اعتبارا من صباح امس السبت
تعقد في جيبوتي اليوم قمه ثلاثيه مصغره
تجمع رئيس دوله جنوب السودان ورئيس لجنه
الوساطه لدول الايجاد بشان الازمه
السودانيه الى جانب الرئيسيين الكيني
والجيبوتي واقلت المتحدثه باسم رئيس دوله
جنوب السودان الجزيره ان القمه ستبحث
التقدم المحرزه في توصيات قمه رؤساء
لبحث وقف دائم لاطلاق النار وفتح الممرات
الانسانيه والدخول في حوار شامل لايجاد حل
للنزاع في السودان
عشيه القمه نقل نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
بالسودان ملك عقار استعداد رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبيا باحمد الكامل لزياره الخرطوم
والجلوس مع طرفين في محاوله للتوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار وذلك رغم ثقته الكامله في وسط
الاليه الافريقيه
اعلن حاكم ومقاطعه في كالوجا روسيا سقوطها
مسيرتين اوكرانيتين في مناطق غير ماهوله
مؤكدا عدم وقوعي اي اضرار او اصابات
اعطى الرئيس الاوكراني اقوى اشاره حتى
الان على ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه الذي جرى
الحديث عنه اصبح قائما حيث قال انه يتم
حاليا اجراءات الهجوم المضاد والاجراءات
الدفاعيه لكنه تكتم في المقابل عن مسار
هذا الهجوم وتفاصيله
قال المتحدث باسم قياده عمليه شرق
اوكرانيا ان قوتهم تقدمت نحو كيلومتر ونصف
الكيلومتر باتجاه منطقه بخموت من اتجاهات
مختلفه جنوبا اعلنا قائد عمليات منطقه
تغاريا جنوب شرقيه اوكرانيا تنفيذ قواتهم
لهجماته وانها الحقت خسائر باربع وحدات
عسكريه روسيه في محور زابروجيا
استدعت الخارجيه الصينيه سفيره كوريا
الجنوبيه لديها وبلغته شكواها من
الانتقادات التي وجهتها سولو
بشان تصريحات عن العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه واقل متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه ان بلاده قلقه بشده عن استدعاء
كوريا الجنوبيه للسفير الصيني لديها
واحتجاجها على تعليقات حذر فيها سول من
القيام برهانات خاطئه ازاء التنافس بين
الصين والولايات المتحده وكانت كوريا
الجنوبيه وصفت هذه التصريحات بانها
استفزازيه وراءت انها تمثل تدخلًا صينيا
في شؤونها الداخليه
انتهى الموجز لما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل
خير
[موسيقى]